[Music]
you jealous girlie
give me a little marking hey i'm talking
to you
if you want it so much all you got to do
is kill me take it
oh come on what do you say you want to
dance
it's your blood gotta go
[Applause]
fight no harry potter
cute real cute
let's see drop down again
is that the only move you know mate
yeah yeah put a shirt on magic mike
uh
[Music]
first learned about this seven years ago
on a mission in brazil
to capture a wanted fugitive
we got there it tore through our unit in
seconds
the target has superhuman abilities
it had the same marking you do cole
it's a birthmark what do you mean he was
born with it
it's not a birthmark cole means you've
been chosen
throughout history different cultures
all over the world
reference a great tournament
of champions that dragon marking
i think it's an invitation to fight for
something known
[Applause]
as mortal kombat
these are your champions i'm sonia
that's kano i'm lou kang
name's jax
the fate of earth is in our hands
no matter how many of my people we put
in the ground
we will not fail kill them
[Music]
i am sub-zero
[Applause]
get over
you [ __ ] beauty
listen carefully watch
learn mortal kombat has begun
there's the war coming we need to fight
before it's too late
mortal kombat has started as this very
simple 8-bit fighting game
that was revolutionary at the time i
liked the idea that we could bring
these characters to a level that hadn't
really been seen before
in the games for fighting this brutal
fight
and so you've got to hire these people
that have that ability
the fight scene's so epic
it's mind-blowing what they do really
the fatalities are sickeningly violent
flawless victory but we all knew that we
needed to cast some really
amazing talented people to make it feel
real
lewis tannen's an incredible athlete
incredible fighter
a guy worked so hard was just
unbelievable
he just did not stop
[Music]
i come from a fighting background real
martial arts to me is very similar to
acting because it's all about
expression there's so much fighting in
this movie that a lot of times after
shooting one fight
we need to practice for some other fight
that's going to take place because we
just don't have
enough time
i knew joe was going to be sub-zero from
day one
joe's got that pure athleticism
i made the mistake of watching the raid
a couple nights before we fought i got i
gotta fight this dude
i gotta fight i gotta fight that dude
joe was faster than everyone joe was too
fast
it was so fast i had to ask him to slow
it down for the camera it was like two
guys
that's ever happened to joe taslim and
bruce lee
a five scene and a drama scene they are
the same in a drama you have the lines
but in a fight it's just
the agony struggle the pain those are
our lines
you cast for what's in their brain what
they've learned over the years
especially with someone like martial art
it's impossible to bring someone up to
his level
quickly that's just not going to happen
the same goes for hiroyuki sonata they
both have a very similar set of
qualities in that they have a presence
they have a look about them
[Music]
we try to make a contrast between
sub-zero and
scorpio a little mixture between game
and
authentic japanese style
watching those two on set was one of the
great privileges i'll ever have in my
life
[Music]
you